it progressed all the way down and the
day after I was down to my neck it's
taken Emily Cleary almost a year to
recover from the mumps but it's worse
her face was so swollen she almost
choked to death for me
the swelling lasted for a week I had
constant migraines
I couldn't sleep because of the pain and
the risk of choking aside from the risk
of meningitis the side effects from
catching the mumps as an adult were
painful and prolonged I was diagnosed
with post viral fatigue which is a form
of MS which meant that I was rendered
incapacitated sometimes for a day
sometimes for two days and that all
lasted for up to six months after in
England cases of mumps have hit their
highest levels for a decade mostly
driven by outbreaks in the universities
of students who have never been
vaccinated
a total of 2028 cases of mumps were
recorded between April and June the
highest quarterly figures since 2009 and
nearly half of those who contracted the
disease were unvaccinated
there were also 301 new measles
infections confirmed in England over the
same period a 30 percent increase on the
three months before public health
England says it clearly shows why we
need sustained high rates of vaccination
many blame the impact of this man's
research former British doctor Andrew
Wakefield for sowing seeds of doubt
about vaccines back in 1998 his claims
that it could be linked to autism caused
the UK's immunization rate to plunge
even though his work has been
discredited it's still doing damage
circulated widely online by the growing
aunt Eve acts
normally what would happen is that a
young child would get the first MMR
vaccine about the aro age of 1 and then
they'd have what a booster before they
go to school clearly as people get older
that might go off but the concerns are
about particularly teenagers and people
who are going to university because
we're seeing a big increase in that
group and in many cases actually it's
because they've never had the MMR
vaccine when they were much younger
a mum two young kids who have had every
vaccinations they were supposed to emily
was told she could have contracted it
from a child who wasn't the doctor told
me the chances are that I caught it from
an unvaccinated child and the fact that
somebody I don't even know has caused me
all these problems I fight fine it I'm
very angry
Katie Spencer Sky News